The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
OK, so to begin.
So in the last class
we talked to them
about some of the early
documentary films.
The films by Nanook of the
North by Flaherty and Man
With a Movie Camera by Dziga
Vertov, and in today's class
we're going to be shifting
a bit and thinking
a bit more about the
question of the relationship
between documentary
film and science.
And one of the things that
many commentators argue often
links science and
documentary in terms
of people's common
perception of it,
is that there's often a tendency
to think of both of them
as offering unmediated access
onto the world out there.
So there's often
the strong tendency
for people to see documentaries
simply a window onto reality,
rather than being an
interpretation of the reality
that's out there.
And certainly, that's
the case for science,
and an even stronger
sense that for many people
the idea is that they like to
think of science as allowing
completely direct access to
the outer physical world.
But many science
studies scholars
would argue that
science doesn't just
simply offer unmediated
access onto the world.
How do scientists
measure or monitor
or present the natural world?
Often they have to do so
through technical instruments,
for example.
And those instruments serve
as a form of mediation.
And when scientists use those
instruments, for example,
or they might use visual
pictures or diagrams based
on what those
instruments might say,
those visual images also have
to be perceived or interpreted.
And this is
increasingly the case,
given computer simulations.
So for example, I
have a student who's
working on the issue
of uranium mining.
And it used to be the
case that when people--
when geologists went off to
do work on uranium mining,
they would go off and do actual
field work at geological sites,
and that would be
the basis of work,
but now increasingly
geologists are
relying on statistical
modeling to find out
where they think that uranium
deposits might be, for example.
So there's an increasing way
with the use of computers
and visual modeling that
visual images and diagrams
and pictures become
increasingly central to how
science gets conveyed or talked
about or thought through.
So if you think about
those visual images,
you always have it.
How are those visual
images constructed?
How do people
interpret those images?
How do they think through them?
So there's all these kinds
of layers of interpretation
and mediation that happened
through those kinds
of visual images.
And then for scientists when
they want to talk or write
about their work, or they
want to convey it to others,
we have to do it
through speaking, right?
We rely upon the
language that we use.
And there are certain
conventions then about, well,
how do you write up the science
that you're engaged in doing?
How do you persuade
fellow scientists
that this is a good argument?
What are the conventions
within your discipline
about what makes a good
or convincing argument?
So all of these different kinds
of representation and language
help to mediate how we perceive
and understand the world
that we're part of.
In addition to whatever
our own personal kind
of social positioning or
institutional positioning
might be.
And similarly documentary
film theorists
would argue that
documentary film also
doesn't offer just
simply unmediated access
onto the world.
I mean, documentary films
are about the real world,
but they're also interpretations
of what that real world is.
So and again, it's not to
say that some interpretations
aren't better than others,
because some interpretations
are better than others.
But filmmakers do-- I
mean obviously filmmakers
choose their subjects.
They choose what to
shoot, they choose
what to exclude
from the frame, they
choose how to create a
narrative out of those images
through the process of editing.
And then you also have
the issue of the subjects
that documentary
filmmakers are filming,
what are those subjects
interpretations of the world?
And then you have the
people who at the end
view the film who have their
interpretations of what
they think is going on.
So you have the subjects
who are being filmed,
their interpretations and
mediations of the world.
You have the filmmaker
creating mediations
of what's going on through
what the filmmaker is doing,
and then you have the
people who watch it
at the end who are interpreting
and meeting it at the same end.
So you have all these
kinds of different layers
of interpretation that all
go on as people make and view
documentary films.
And so in this class I just
want to briefly, just very
briefly talk about some
social science perspectives
on thinking about science.
And that got referred to in your
reading a bit as STS studies,
and I know that article--
there was a kind of an overview
article that I gave you
by Susan [? Silver, ?] who's
the chair of the department here
actually, and Sophia [? Rus. ?]
I it's a difficult article.
You're not really expected to--
most of you are undergraduates,
except Catarina.
Catarina has to understand it.
But for the rest
of you, the point
is just to give you some
sense of the terrain
of the arguments,
and you're not really
expected to know all the ins
and outs and details of all
that literature.
But just suffice to say that
social studies of science,
it gets called by
different names.
Science studies, social
studies of science,
STS, lots of other different
names we won't go into,
has been an interdisciplinary
venture by historians,
philosophers, anthropologists,
sociologists, and others
that gained considerable
momentum during the 1960s
and '70s, and it's
offered a way to think
about science in social terms.
To stand back a bit
from the science
and think about what it is in
terms of the ideas at work.
Not only the ideas
at work, but also
in terms of the
people who practice
that science, the
communities and institutions
that they're part of.
And these are important
social questions for us
to be thinking about, right?
Because science and
modern technologies
are so incredibly crucial
to our contemporary lives.
They shape how we
live, how we think
in the world, the kinds of
policy decisions that get made,
the health of our bodies,
the kinds of knowledge
we consider valid.
I mean so these
are all completely
central social questions.
So for social scientists
and philosophers,
these kinds of
questions around science
are also extremely important.
So it's not only important
for science and engineers,
but it's also important for
people in other disciplines
to be thinking about
these kinds of questions.
And I just want to throw out
a couple of important points
that science studies
has made that I
think it might be
useful for all of us
in thinking about this class.
And as you think about
your final projects,
and you think about what kind
of project do you want to do,
it might help a bit
in thinking about it.
So one important insight
from science studies
is that instead of seeing,
well, here's society over here,
and here's science over
here, and they're somehow
separate in opposition
to each other.
That one of the major
points of science studies
is that you always have
to see science and society
as being co-produced or in
relationship to each other.
And maybe some of this sounds
a bit obvious, I'm not sure.
But obviously science comes
out of our social world.
It's part of the social
world in which we exist.
Science gets produced by people
in particular historical times
and places.
And because of the times and
places in which we all exist,
we ask certain
kinds of questions
and we don't ask other
kinds of questions.
The time periods in
which we're operating
shapes what we consider
to be important or not.
It shapes what
gets funded or not.
And science-- as
Susan Sylvia argues,
science is a communal process.
For the most part it happens
through institutions.
It's a collective
enterprise that
happens at places like MIT,
and in through other kinds
of institutions.
Students get trained in
particular kinds of ways.
Again, there's
whole funding bodies
that operate in
certain kinds of ways,
and they fund certain kinds
of issues and not others.
And so we have to
think of science
as being fundamentally a social
or collective kind of activity.
OK?
And I just want to make
very clear, though,
that this does not
in any way undermine
the validity or the importance
of the knowledge that comes out
of science.
And if anything I would argue
that it adds a certain richness
and appreciation to
understanding it,
because there's also these whole
layers of social complexity
that are also part
of it as well.
So that's one crucial point.
Secondly another crucial
point is that science studies
has shifted even
in its own thinking
from not only thinking
about the content
of scientific knowledge, but
also to thinking about science
as something that people do.
Right?
And so you have a number
of science studies scholars
that engage--
that have been engaged
in laboratory studies.
So they go and they spend
time in lab laboratories
because they want to
pay attention to science
as a process.
What do scientists actually do?
How do they know what they know?
How do they think about it?
How do they learn it?
How do they train
their students?
How does this affect the
ways that knowledge ends up
being produced?
OK?
And so you have social
scientists scholars
who do work in laboratories.
One of the articles
that you read for today
by Sharon Traweek-- she's
done a very famous ethnography
called Beamtimes and Lifetimes
where she did research
in laboratories with physicists,
both in the US and in Japan.
Which is quite an
interesting study.
I sometimes use it in anthro.
It's a good read, if
anybody is interested.
And then you have other social
science studies scholars
that also look at scientists
beyond the laboratory.
So you have Hugh
Gusterson, somebody
else who used to teach here
at MIT who no longer does.
He's at George Mason now.
But he did work with
nuclear weapons designers
at Livermore Lab.
And because it
was classified, he
couldn't get access to
where they were actually
doing the work.
And so he ended up kind of
lurking around Livermore
Lab basically on the outside.
And so he would go to
coffee shops with people,
go to their houses.
He would go to church,
he would go shopping.
And he would do these
really in-depth interviews
with people.
And so he spent a lot of
time hanging out in the areas
where nuclear weapons
designers were
spending time talking to them.
And he became-- it was very
interesting in his work
from the beginning, it was
kind of like well who are you?
And then afterwards I think
people came to so enjoy
telling their story to him.
Because a lot of people
hadn't had a chance
to tell their story about what
they did and why they did it
and how they thought about it in
moral in other kinds of terms,
that it became the thing
to do that everybody
wanted to be
interviewed by Hugh.
And so everybody is like, well,
you interviewed everybody else.
How come you haven't
interviewed me yet?
So he kind of became the
resident anthropologist
of all the nuclear weapons
folks at Livermore Lab.
And then you have
Stefan Helmreich,
who's another science study
scholar here at MIT who
also, he did work with
marine microbiologists,
and following them around
not only in laboratories,
but taking a trip down
in Alvin under the water,
going to conferences,
other places
where scientists might go.
So you have a number of science
study scholars doing work
on what is it that
scientists are doing,
and following scientists
around where they go.
And so the big
question from this
is, how does science
potentially look
different when we think about
it as something that people do?
Do we think about
science differently when
you think about it as a
process, as an activity,
rather than simply some data
that you get in a textbook?
If you think about
it as an activity,
I think a lot of scholars
who do this kind of work
would argue it actually kind
of opens up and frees up
a lot of ways of
thinking about science.
And that's particularly
going to be relevant for us,
since film is a medium
that focuses on activity.
So the third issue I
wanted to throw out
is that science study
scholarship has also
been helpful in thinking
about questions of science
and technology as they travel
throughout our social world,
even apart from scientists
and other kinds of folks.
So the question of how
do debates about science
spread through other aspects
of not only US society,
but other regions of the world.
So you can think about
this question, say--
I mean lots of different
ways to think about it.
But in relation to environmental
pollution is one example.
So if people live in
a community that they
have concerns about
environmental pollution,
science becomes really
crucial in terms
of trying to figure
out, well, what
is the nature of the pollution?
What is the extent of it?
There might be debates about
what kinds of knowledge
gets counted or
doesn't get counted.
But for a lot of people
in their day to day lives,
I mean science is
obviously something
that's a crucial part
just for average people
in terms of living in
the contemporary world.
And internationally
you think about
international development,
a lot of the language
of international
development projects
uses managerial
language, but also
language of science, science
and technology as part of it.
So there's all these
questions about, well,
what are the discussions
about science and technology
and all these spaces apart from
laboratories and scientists
in places like MIT.
How does it work out
there in the world?
And part of the reason I think
that's important for this class
is, again, as you think
about your final projects,
we're encouraging people
to do final projects
around science and technology.
But we also want you to
think broadly about that.
You don't have to just think
doing science in a lab.
Although that can be
really fascinating.
You know, so if you can
think of a good project
you want to do based on that,
that could be fantastic.
But if you also want to
follow things outside of MIT,
or take an unconventional
angle on this, do it.
You'd be creative with this.
Think about how
this stuff moves,
how it goes to different
kinds of places,
what do people do with it.
So anyway, so we want you to
be thinking in those terms.
OK.
So and just once again
to emphasize this point
that for us in
thinking of this class,
we really want to be thinking
about science as a process.
Not only questions about
knowledge as an end product,
but a process of what do
scientists do, how do they
come to know, what are the
relationships that scientists
are part of.
How does science and
technology circulate out there?
What kinds of debates
are they part of?
What are the implications
of the debates?
Now I lost my next page.
Sorry.
Anyway.
Sorry, I had file
conversion problems.
So I got a bit stuck here.
Anyway, OK.
And I think this
focus on practices,
again, is useful for
many different reasons.
In addition to thinking
about the film angle.
But also thinking of science
as a kind of practice
or as a process I think also
helps to make science human.
Right?
It helps to bring the human
element back in, and make
science more approachable.
And again, this is also relevant
for thinking about doing
documentary films about this.
And it's also focusing on
how people come to have--
also by focusing on how
people come to have knowledge
that you gain appreciation
for that kind of knowledge
as well as you see the
limitations of that knowledge.
Right?
When you focus on,
well, how are we
going about getting knowledge?
What are we able to get
access to, or what not?
What's the potential
constraints?
What's the things that
we're really good at?
Isn't it amazing
that people were
able to figure this
kind of thing out?
But what's the kind
of stuff that's
difficult to think about?
That it's actually by following
these activities of science
that we get a stronger
sense, and again, I
think a richer sense of
what do we know well,
and what do we know less well.
And as we've talked
about earlier in class,
part of the goal of
this class is also
thinking about documentary
film as a process itself.
So again, we're not just
looking at documentary films
as a product.
Right?
We're not just looking
at the final product.
We're also trying
to think about what
were the context in
which the films got
made, what were the social
relationships like that
were part of the
documentary filmmaking, what
kinds of choices got made.
Both the aesthetic
choices, but also choices
between relationships between
subjects and audiences.
What got included in the films?
What got left out of the films?
So we're thinking
back to the discussion
we had about Vertov and
Flaherty so all those questions
were become important, right?
I mean, what were
the social context
in which those films were made?
Who were they made for?
How were choices made, what
were the relationships that
got set up through the
making of documentary film?
So we're thinking about
both science as a process,
and we're thinking
about documentary
filmmaking as a process.
And so the idea of this class
is to put the two of them
together.
So thinking about the process
of documentary filmmaking,
thinking about
science as a process,
and hopefully trying to make
videos and films about that.
OK?
The conjuncture where
they both come together.
And again, we're
going to go back
to this at the end of the
class where we talk more
about your final projects.
But first we want to show you
some documentary films that
have been made about science.
And I just wanted to throw--
I'm going to be tethered,
so this will be a little bit
difficult. OK, but as we talked
about in the very first class,
science films have
always been there
from the very beginning
of filmmaking.
As we saw early on from
those 1905 films by Charles
[? Urban ?] that we discussed.
So very, very long history.
But we want to list some of
the ways in which filmmaking
and science have come together.
And I just want to list four.
And maybe you all can
help me think of others.
But one major way has been
for some people, anyway,
to think of a film or video
as a means of collecting data.
Right?
How can how can we use
film or video as a way
to collect data, to collect
information about the world?
So whether it's about using film
or video to slow things down,
do things in slow
motion that we wouldn't
be able to see otherwise,
potentially speed things up.
So a whole range
of what can you do
with these kinds of technologies
that allows you to see--
not only allows
you to see things
in different kinds of ways,
but that you can actually
use as data.
And then there's the whole
range of other things
that this can lead off
into in the sciences where
you have all kinds of
imaging techniques,
where you could be brain
scans, or other kinds of scans.
So that's a whole other
kind of using visual images
as data collection.
But here we're focusing
on particular kinds
of uses of film and
video as data collecting.
Another way the two
have been linked
is this question of how can
we use film or video as a way
to go out and explore the world?
How can we use
these instruments,
these technologies to
explore these worlds,
these social worlds
around science?
Or questions that science
might raise for us.
How do we use them?
Can we use them as
tools of exploration?
OK.
A third way in which
they have been linked
is an obvious one
that's probably
familiar to all of
us, is education.
Right?
And there's two aspects of this.
One coming from the
end of the scientists,
and one coming from the
end of the filmmakers.
OK?
So a question is then, for
scientists, the question--
one of the main questions about
film and video could be how can
we use these kinds
of technologies
in order to educate
people about the sciences.
And then one of the primary
questions for the scientists
become, how do we take
the work that we've done
and convey that in visual terms?
What are the means we
can use to convey this?
And these are difficult
questions, right?
And these are also
difficult questions
for scientists when they write.
Because how do you explain
to other people what
it is that you're working
on, and often scientists
have to rely upon certain
kinds of written metaphors
to try to explain what
they're getting at.
Are those metaphors-- I
mean and do the metaphors--
I mean they never quite
exactly work, right?
And so one of the questions
that scientists always
to have to think about then is,
is the metaphor that I'm using,
is it helpful or is it
potentially leading things
astray?
OK?
And the same kinds
of questions then
when scientists want to
use visual technologies.
When you're using film and
video to try to educate people
about the sciences, what kinds
of visual images or narratives
are you going to use to try
to convey that information.
And what's the potential
benefits or constraints
about the way that
you choose to do it.
So that becomes a major
question for scientists.
For filmmakers one of the
major questions becomes, well,
what kinds of
narratives can you use
to talk about the
science that are going
to keep people interested?
Right?
I mean so their
goal also has to be,
how do you make something
interesting that people
want to see?
So it becomes, well, what
interests people about science?
How do I convey something in a
visually interesting way that
tells a story in a way
that will bring people
in where they'll want to
learn more about the science?
OK?
So these kinds of questions
about how we use film and video
as means of education.
OK.
And then also certainly
within popular culture,
there's also just a lot of
fascination with science.
Right?
So then there's also using
film and video technologies
as a way to satisfy popular
curiosity about science
in a way that might not quite
be strictly educational.
So again, we talk to them
about the IMAX films,
and they might be somewhat
educational, somewhat
entertainment.
But in a way that
satisfies public curiosity
about the sciences.
OK?
And so first we're going to
think about all of these a bit
as we watch various
clips tonight.
And the first one we're
going to think about
is using film and video as a
technique for generating data.
And we're going to be doing
this through the figure of Doc
Edgerton.
Any of you know who
Doc Edgerton was?
[? Anita? ?]
AUDIENCE: He has a
[? sense ?] [INAUDIBLE]..
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah, so Doc
Edgerton was-- he trained here.
He was born in 1903,
he died in 1990.
He was a legend.
CHRIS BOEBEL: He died
in the MIT faculty club.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Did he really?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Collapsed
and died, yes.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Really?
Oh, that's horrible.
CHRIS BOEBEL: In 1990, yes.
Anyway.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Wow.
He had been a faculty member
here at MIT for 40 years.
He had been here as
an undergraduate.
He went off and did research
at GE, I believe it was,
for a few years and then he came
back to do his PhD here at MIT.
And he became interested--
he was working with motors.
And one of the things
that he noticed
when he was doing his work
that when there were problems
with electrical transmission
lines and the lights
would flicker, that he
could observe changes
in the motion of the motor
that he couldn't otherwise.
And so what he ended up
doing during the 1930s
was he developed a
repeatable short duration
electronic flash, or a
stroboscopic light that could
reveal motion in segments.
So you could capture
fast motion in a way
that was not accessible
to our normal perception.
So he did-- I mean, I
didn't write it down,
but I think it's in here,
exactly how it worked.
So Edgerton called his
unit a stroboscope.
It could emit 60 10-microsecond
flashes per second,
a hitherto unimaginable speed.
OK?
So through his
invention Doc Edgerton
was able to capture
things using photography,
so it's he did both still
photography, but also
obviously if you do still
photography that quickly
and you run it together,
you have moving images.
So this is also the intersection
of photography and moving
pictures.
So he did this
fascinating work where
he did extraordinarily
famous work, again,
both in still photography
and in moving images.
I'm sure many of
you have seen his,
even if you're not aware
that they were necessarily
Doc Edgerton's work.
His work became
extremely famous.
He-- actually there was a short.
There was a short film that
was made about his work,
I think it was in the 1940s
that won an Academy Award.
His work was shown all over.
And it also crossed the boundary
between science and art,
where some of his work was just
seen as so gorgeous that it was
shown in museums as artwork.
So he was kind of working
on that boundary then
between the world of science
and the world of art.
He also did other things as
well with a couple of students
from here at MIT.
He became involved during
the Second World War
in classified military work.
So they did work on inventions
for aerial reconnaissance,
aerial photography.
And then also later they
did photographic images
of nuclear weapons blasts.
And there's actually
some online,
you can actually see them if
you're interested in that.
He worked with Jacques
Cousteau, helping
Jacques Cousteau develop
underwater camera equipment.
So he was an inventor.
He was a scientist.
He was-- some people
would call him an artist.
He said, "Don't make
me out to be an artist.
I'm an engineer.
I am after the facts,
only the facts."
But what his work I think
suggests for a lot of people
is, can work that is science
also be art at the same time?
So anyway so let's watch a few.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So
yeah, I don't know
which ones you want to watch.
You should drive.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: OK.
So that was a bit of
an introductory one.
So here's another one of
this famous milk drop pieces,
but this is later in color.
And I'm sure you've seen
some of his famous stills.
Have seen the one with the
still photograph with the apple
with a bullet going through it?
Have ever seen that image?
You've seen the
photograph, yeah.
Which he famously titled,
"Making Applesauce at MIT."
And you might have seen
this famous one of a card,
with a bullet going through
a card, like still images.
They were shown them in
publications like Life
during their time.
I mean, they really
circulated widely.
Let me show you a few more.
AUDIENCE: I think
a couple of them
are on display in building 34.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah,
I wouldn't be surprised,
because the 150th anniversary,
there's a lot of interest in--
and I think the MIT Museum is--
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah, the museum.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Is doing a
Doc Edgerton display right now
because the 150th anniversary.
So there's probably a
fair amount of stuff
around right now.
Hummingbird.
This is really pretty, too.
AUDIENCE: There's a milk
drop poster in Lobby 7.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Milk
drop poster in the Lobby 7.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah that's
right, that's right, yeah.
And if anybody has any doubt
about whether or not he
actually had artistic
sensibilities or intentions,
I mean look at the way he set
that up with the red, red cup,
and it's--
AUDIENCE: Even the
shape of the plate.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah,
I know, exactly.
Yeah.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
So this is back
to one of the older
black and whites.
So there's tons
of stuff on here.
We could see a range
of different things
depending on what your interest.
Do you want to see
a nuclear blast?
Do you want to see--
some of them it's
very interesting,
it goes back to the very first
stuff that we saw from 1905.
There's also time lapse
of plants unfolding,
the same way we saw in
the very early pieces.
So again, a similar kind of--
remember back to those
very early pieces
where they were of
interest to scientists,
but they were also shown
in public theaters,
with kind of vaudeville
music in the background.
So they were meant to be
both popular entertainment.
And so I mean he's
differently positioned
with the scientific institution,
but still an interest
in engaging a broader audience.
And again, kinds of
images that people--
that many people found
very fascinating.
But there's nuclear
explosions, you
can see him hanging out
with Jacques Cousteau.
And there's a whole
range of different things
we can look at.
Oh, the pigeon is cool.
I'll do this pigeon one before
we do the Science Reporter.
OK.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Just
watch a few minutes.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: This
one-- we'll just watch.
This is the half hour
episode about him
that gives a little
context, but we'll just
watch a few minutes of it.
JOHN FITCH: You are watching
a swimmer taking pictures
with an underwater camera.
But below a few hundred
feet, as the light disappears
and the pressures become too
great for human endurance,
other techniques for
photographing the silent world
in the deep oceans
have to be used.
These techniques for
deep sea photography
are our story today
on Science Reporter.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello, I'm John Fitch,
MIT science reporter.
We're at the MIT
swimming pool today
to talk to a man who has
made major contributions
to the science of photography.
He is Dr. Harold
Edgerton, a professor
of electrical measurements
in the Department
of Electrical
Engineering at MIT,
the man who is both an
inventor and a teacher,
and internationally famous as
the father of modern high speed
photography.
At the edge of 28, Dr. Edgerton
invented an electronic device
which allowed invisible motion,
much too fast for the human eye
to see, such as the
swing of a golf club,
or the path of a
bullet in flight,
to be frozen onto a
single photographic plate.
More recently Dr.
Edgerton has been
adapting his
electronic flash lamps
to photograph
another world which
is invisible to the naked eye.
The world of the ocean depths.
Some of the equipment designed
by Dr. Edgerton for deep sea
photography is set up
here at the swimming pool,
and we're going to
meet Dr. Edgerton
and learn more about it.
HAROLD EDGERTON: Everything
worked all right?
Fine, then we'll have it
covered from several angles.
JOHN FITCH: Dr. Edgerton?
That looks very much
like an ordinary camera.
What keeps the water out
from ruining the film?
HAROLD EDGERTON:
Well, this camera
is like an ordinary
camera, except a case.
[INAUDIBLE] waterproof case.
It was developed in France by
the captain Jacques Cousteau
whom I've met many times.
It's now made in Japan.
This lens, for
example, comes out,
and the lens is protected by
rubber rings called O rings
which seal against a surface.
JOHN FITCH: So how
do you focus and set
the distance and aperture
and all those things?
HAROLD EDGERTON: When
you turn those knobs,
you see one of them changes
focus, the other one changes
the aperture.
JOHN FITCH: Very clever.
HAROLD EDGERTON: And this
fits in through the O rings.
And that seals.
Now I'm not going
to take this apart,
because it has film in here.
But if you pull these two
levers, the entire mechanism,
camera mechanism comes out,
and you can get at the film.
JOHN FITCH: That's
also sealed in?
HAROLD EDGERTON:
It's also sealed in,
and you trigger
the thing by means
of a pusher at this point.
Release.
JOHN FITCH: I notice
you also had-- he took
his own life along with him.
HAROLD EDGERTON: Yes, of course
every picture must have light,
and in underwater it's
particularly important
because the sunlight does
not penetrate too well,
and you always want
to film in shadows.
So of course, in
this day and age--
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Jacques
Cousteau's equipment
was developed with Doc Edgerton
in the alumni pool right
over there, which is
where this is shot.
So it's of those kinds
of amazing things
about walking around
MIT campus when
you start to learn
more about the history
and everything was
going on in these spaces
that we don't really pay that
much attention to as we just
walk around.
But we can-- have you
had enough of Doc?
Or do you want to see a
nuclear explosion or something?
Or a plant unfolding?
Or flowers or nuclear explosion.
CHRIS BOEBEL: The nuclear
explosions-- there.
Yeah, let's take a quick look.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: OK.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Here we go.
He actually did some really
extraordinary still photos.
I mean, just images
you've never seen before
of the first few microseconds
of a nuclear explosion
when it's still this tiny,
tightly packed ball of energy,
and it doesn't look like
a nuclear explosion.
It's really amazing.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: OK.
So reactions,
thoughts, comments?
AUDIENCE: I think it's
kind of interesting how
allowing the camera
to run faster
lets you actually slow it down,
because I was trying to think
like, why does that work?
But then it's like the
more frames you have,
when you play them
back at normal speed,
it moves at a slower pace.
I just thought that was
interesting in terms
of what the technology says.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yes.
I'm sorry, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I think it's also
cool how he [INAUDIBLE] the milk
and how it changes the surface
of [INAUDIBLE],, and then
also [INAUDIBLE]
nuclear explosion,
pushing [INAUDIBLE]
completely different scale.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
And to this question
of how it works,
I mean so the
description given here.
Synchronized with the camera
so that with each flash
a frame of film was exposed.
The flashing light decomposed
the phases of movement.
This is back to when
he was originally
doing his original
things with the motors.
Decomposed the phases of
movement of one of his motors
into 3,000 images per second.
So at that point it
was a third faster
than anybody else had
been able to produce.
And it was fast enough that
when the film was projected
at normal speed the swift
turning of the motor
could be studied in slow motion.
So again, how
exactly it all works.
Other reactions, thoughts?
AUDIENCE: How aesthetically
appealing it is.
I mean it's very
interesting to see
the movement of the wings
of the bird, but most of all
it's just beautiful.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Can science be art?
[? CHRIS BOEBEL: ?] Well,
that's a really interesting
relationship between
data and art.
And it's something that
you see continuing.
For those of you who
saw Tom Schillings piece
that he made for
our last class that
was shown at last
week, the museum.
One of the things among
others that strikes me
about some of the AFM nano
images that are in that piece
is how beautiful they are.
And so if you watch the
piece, you start to wonder,
are they beautiful because it
just happened to be beautiful,
or are they beautiful
because the people making
them and designing the
machines that create them
that are these analogs
to something that's real
have a bias towards
making them beautiful?
AUDIENCE: This reminds
me of-- there's
a museum in London, the
Wellcome Collection.
And there was an
exhibition where
there was a competition
on the kind of imaging
of bodily tissues, and
kind of medical imaging,
and the competition.
And there was an exhibition
of the best 15 works selected,
and they were showing
tissue with cancer
and all sorts of
very intimate kind
of horrible details
of disease, but it was
like an aesthetic competition.
These were selected for
their aesthetic qualities.
And it's kind of incredible.
So you walk into the collection,
and you didn't really
know what you were
looking at, or how you're
supposed to relate to it.
CHRIS BOEBEL: I think
the Koch Institute
is doing something similar with
their lobby display area there.
They've had a competition
of bioimaging,
and it's being judged
on certainly not
just scientific merit,
but beauty and aesthetics.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
And I wonder if it
is a shift that's happening
more broadly, whereas I think
a few years back as people--
when people were trained
I think there was a strong
bias that if you had tendencies
towards those
artistic direction,
that somehow undermined
your science.
And you come-- so you
kind of had to choose.
You couldn't be
one or the other,
or you weren't seen as being
credible in one realm if you
were seen as being credible
in the other realm.
But I wonder if that
is breaking down
a bit with the kinds of
new imaging technologies
that you have, which are
incredibly aesthetically
pleasing at the same time.
And I wonder if it's a
similar kind of moment where
maybe the art and the science
are kind of coming together
in a way that maybe hasn't
been true in more recent years.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
it also comes up
[INAUDIBLE] how [? specific ?]
knowledge is used
in relationship with
the studies of violence
we're watching weapons
of mass destruction
and how exactly what is
beautiful, but socially
historical [INAUDIBLE] to
serve the military purposes
of the violence.
So I don't know.
It was a little disturbing.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Yeah, well, yeah.
I mean that's-- I mean, so
there's both flowers unfolding,
and hummingbirds in flight,
and there's also nuclear
detonations.
Right?
So there are-- so there's
both ends of this.
And then there's
the questions of,
as this stuff gets
turned into art,
are you aestheticizing things
like violence, and that's
partly the question you're
raising [INAUDIBLE] things
cancers on people's
bodies, right?
I mean what's the--
is that something that's
properly aestheticized or not?
How are you supposed to relate
to those kinds of images?
Is it appropriate
to look for beauty
in certain kinds of images when
they're images of violence,
for example.
So that raises a whole range
of other kinds of questions.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Which are very
present in film, as well.
I mean, if you think about
the way violence is handled
in mainstream films, that's
clearly an issue that you may
or may not be concerned about.
The aestheticization
of violence.
And it's something that comes
up in documentaries as well.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So, any
further thoughts on all this?
OK, so let's move on.
So the second major use of
science and documentary images
that we're going
to talk about today
is educational, which
we've already mentioned.
And there's obviously
long been an interest
in using film and documentary
as a means to educate
the public about science.
And as I mentioned before,
one of the questions
that immediately comes up
from the end of the scientists
is how do you visually
convey to audiences what it
is that you want them to get.
If you want visual media to
serve as a form of education,
how do you translate
things visually
in a way that actually
will educate your audience
and get them engage
with the topic?
And so then the next piece
that we're going to see
is a film that was made in 1960
called Frames of Reference.
That tries to do this
in an interesting way.
I'd be curious to see
what your reactions are.
It was made by Ricky Leacock.
Ricky Leacock had studied
physics at Harvard,
and he later became a
documentary filmmaker,
an extremely famous
documentary filmmaker
in the direct cinema tradition.
Actually if you think back in
the first class, the images
of a primary with
the JFK election,
he was a camera person for that.
Extreme-- did a number of very
famous films some of which
you might have seen pieces of.
He taught here at
MIT for many years.
There was a film program at MIT
that was extremely influential.
It sort of got phased out
when the Media Lab came in.
But he had been a very
central figure here at MIT.
But this was a film
that he made very early
on with two other
physicists, and this
is before he became a--
he was obviously making
films at this point.
But it was before he went off
and became a direct cinema
filmmaker.
So in the early
years right before.
CHRIS BOEBEL: I think
he was 22, 23 years old.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: OK, so again,
called Frames of Reference
from 1960.
Oh, and he also worked
with Flaherty on something.
He was a camera
person for Flaherty.
Flaherty ended up doing a
film about rural Louisiana,
and he ended up being the
camera person for that as well.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- We're used to seeing things
from a particular point
of view.
That is, from a particular
frame of reference.
And things look different to us
under different circumstances.
At the moment things look--
you look peculiar.
- You're upside down.
- No, you're the one
that's upside down.
- No, you're upside down.
- Well, I'm not.
He's the one that's
upside down, isn't he?
- Well, let's toss for it.
- All right.
OK.
- You lose.
He's the one who's
really upside down.
You better come into my
frame of reference, now.
- My frame of
reference was inverted
from what it usually is.
That view of things
would be normal for me
if I normally
walked on my hands.
This represents a
frame of reference.
Just three rods stuck together
so that each is at right angles
to the other two.
Now I'm going to move
in this direction.
You see the frame at the
same spot on your screen,
but you know I'm moving this way
because we see the wall moving
this way behind me.
But how do you know that
I'm not standing still,
and the wall moving?
It was the wall that was moving.
Now the wall has
disappeared and you
have no way of telling
whether I am moving or not.
But now you know
that I'm moving.
The point of this is that
all motion is relative.
In both cases I was moving
relative to the wall,
and the wall was
moving relative to me.
- All motion is
relative, but we tend
to think of one
thing as being fixed
and the other thing
as being moving.
We usually think of the Earth
as fixed and walls are usually
fixed to the Earth,
so perhaps you
were surprised the first time
when it was the wall that
was moving and not Doctor Hume.
A frame of reference
fixed to the Earth
is the most common
frame of reference
in which to observe the
motion of other things.
This is the frame of
reference that you're used to.
The frame is fastened
to the table.
The table is bolted
to the floor.
The floor is anchored
in the building,
and the building is firmly
attached to the Earth.
Of course, the reason
for having three rods
is the position of any
object such as this ball
can be specified using
these three reference lines.
This reference line points in
the direction which we call up,
which is a different
direction here
than it is on the other
side of the Earth.
And these two reference
lines specify a plane, which
we call horizontal or level.
In this film,
we're going to look
at the motion of objects in
this Earth frame of reference,
and in other frames of reference
moving in different ways
relative to the Earth frame.
Well, let's look at a motion.
This steel ball can be held
up by the electromagnet.
Now I'm going to open
the switch and you
watch the motion of the ball.
The ball is accelerated
straight down by gravity
along a line parallel to
this vertical reference line.
As you can see,
the electromagnet
is mounted on a
cart that can move,
and I'm going to do
exactly the same experiment
that Dr. Hume did, but
this time while the car is
moving at a constant velocity.
The cart is pulled
along by a string which
is wound around this
phonograph turntable,
and that pulls it with
a constant velocity.
When the cart passes
this line the ball
is released, as you can see.
I'm going to start the cart
down at the end of the table
so that by the time it
gets to this point I
can be sure it's moving
with a constant velocity.
Now I want you to watch
right here so that you
will see the ball falling.
I think you can see that
the ball landed in exactly
the same position
that it did before,
when Dr. Hume did the
experiment with the cart fixed.
But this time the ball could
not have fallen straight down.
Let me show you why.
The ball was released
at that point.
If it had fallen straight
down, because the cart moves on
in the time that
it takes the ball
would have landed
back here somewhere.
But it didn't.
I'm going to do the
experiment again,
and this time I'm
going to let you
watch the motion
through a slow motion
camera which is fixed here.
As the cart moves by,
the ball will fall,
and you can watch in
the slow motion camera.
I'll show you this again.
This time there will
be a line on the film
so that you can see the path.
I think that you can see
that the path of the ball
is a parabola.
But all of this has been
in a frame of reference
fixed to the Earth.
How would this motion look
in a frame of reference which
was moving along with the cart?
Frame of reference like that.
Well, so that you can
see what it looks like,
I'm going to fix this
slow motion camera
so that it moves with the cart.
Like this.
I'm going to do the
experiment again.
And incidentally I'll
start it, and then I'm
going to stand here so
that when the ball falls,
you will have something which
is fixed as a reference point.
In a moving frame
of reference I think
you could see that
the path of the ball
is a vertical straight line.
It looks exactly
the same as it did
before when Doctor Hume did the
experiment with the cart fixed.
If we were moving along
in this frame of reference
and we couldn't see
the surroundings,
then we wouldn't be able
to tell by this experiment
that we were moving at
a constant velocity.
As a matter of
fact, we wouldn't be
able to tell by any
experiment that we were
moving at a constant velocity.
I'm going to do the
experiment once more.
And this time I'm not going
to stand here behind the ball
as it falls so that you won't
have any fixed reference frame.
As far as you're
concerned that time,
the cart wasn't
necessarily moving at all.
That time when you couldn't
see the background,
then I think perhaps
it was harder
for you to realize that you were
in a moving frame of reference.
[END PLAYBACK]
CHRIS BOEBEL: So if
anybody's interested,
this is available online.
And this goes on
quite interesting,
lots of great little
toys and experience.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So
reactions, comments?
AUDIENCE: This is a
slightly random comment,
but there was a speck
of paint on the wall.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you could
see that, yeah, moving.
Yeah.
I just thought I'd throw it out.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Now,
I noticed that too.
It's funny because one of the
things I love about this film
is that they have such
great rigs and toys
and they've set it
all up and they make
it really, really easy seeming.
So well, put the
little screw in here,
and now the cameras
attached to the cart.
And the phonograph
turntable will turn it
at a constant speed.
So it all seems
really effortless,
and the whole rig of
the guy upside down
and the camera spinning around.
But yeah, the speck
of paint is just
a little detail they missed.
AUDIENCE: Kind of looks like
these kind of TV chefs program
there.
They have all their money.
Looks really-- so who
was this made for?
CHRIS BOEBEL: It was--
it's an educational film.
It was made with grants.
Grant funding and,
do you know the year?
CHRISTINE WALLEY: 1960.
CHRIS BOEBEL: 1960, yeah.
AUDIENCE: And for schools?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah, for schools.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: To educate
people about physics.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah.
I think it's the
whole idea of laying
the foundation for relativity
and just understanding
how speeds are--
objects are either fixed
or not fixed depending
on where the observer is.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: But
what it's very famous for
is that at the beginning.
The opening with-- as you can
imagine, which is quite a--
I mean so that's something
to think about, too, then,
as you go to think
about making films,
not that you're expected
to put that much effort.
But they were trying
to think about, well,
how would you convey something
in a visually arresting way
to a general audience
that would really
make the point that they're
talking about in terms
of frames of reference.
And I mean it is kind of a
brilliant way to get into it,
and it takes an
incredible amount of work.
I mean you think about how much
work they put into it, as Chris
said, setting up all of these
rigs to actually convey that.
But the kind of forethought
that goes into, well,
how do you convey what
you want to convey,
if you want to educate someone
about these kinds of concepts?
How would you translate
that individual terms?
CHRIS BOEBEL: And the way
certain visual images persist.
Everybody who sees this film
remembers that beginning.
You may not remember
anything else,
but everybody
remembers that opening.
AUDIENCE: I think very
effective because--
CHRISTINE WALLEY: It is perfect.
AUDIENCE: It's effective the
first thing, because you--
I mean if we see
something like that.
You wouldn't think that that's
actually, that that's real.
[INAUDIBLE] that's just a trick.
But I was confused, like um.
But it doesn't-- it's very
old, it can't be a trick?
How did they do it?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Right, exactly.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's
because this is old?
Do we really expect it?
But right now
[INAUDIBLE] whatever.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Right, true enough.
It wouldn't carry quite
the same cachet today.
It's true.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well,
that's why, even then I
mean they had some ability
to manipulate space and do
composites and so on.
But that's why you have to pull
out and see the quarter fall
and see him flip around.
It's very much a
magician showing you
how it's done, rather than
just having it stay magic.
AUDIENCE: Very simple
comment, the fact
that they're talking
to you, and that you
are at the same time,
of course, to watch
the film, but also watching
what's happening in the film,
and I think these are
two different things.
And it's definitely an
effective educational strategy.
CHRIS BOEBEL: It's
also kind of--
it's obvious but
it's worth saying
that it's an interesting
example of the camera is you.
I mean of course, they're
talking to the camera,
but it's also ride
along on the cart.
And the camera goes on the cart,
and then you're on the cart.
You are the camera.
You, the audience.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] because
you are a different camera.
Sometimes so you see the
camera and then you enter.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And then
you become that camera.
Yes, you do switch.
Sometimes you're a
different camera.
AUDIENCE: It also on that
point, it's also interesting
that throughout the
whole piece you--
like from the very-- after
the first scene then you start
thinking, oh, I'm
going to be tricked.
I need to pay attention.
Think about what's happening.
And I think that's also
really effective in engaging
the audience.
It also just makes
it really interesting
because you're like, it's
kind of like a puzzle.
Trying to figure out.
What are they going to do next.
Like I can't be tricked.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah,
well, and you think back
to Flaherty, again, when
he was doing the igloo,
and when Nanook does the
window, and he doesn't tell you
immediately what's
going on, you're
supposed to watch
and figure it out.
So that's one of the
things that filmmakers
do use very effectively
to pull audiences in,
is to allow the audience to
be able to discover things
through the process of
filmmaking without just telling
them everything.
Or the idea here that you better
pay attention because there's
going to be something going on.
There's going to be some
kind of trick involved.
Again, how do you
engage your audience
and get them and emotionally
involved in what's going on.
And sometimes revealing
is the way to do it.
And sometimes not
revealing certain things
can be the way to do it.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Making it
like a puzzle, as you said.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: As you said,
exactly, making like a puzzle.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And then
just one last thing.
Another very small thing
that I think is cool.
We talked in the first class
about the plastic elements
of film, and all of
the different things
you can change and
techniques you can use,
and obviously there's a lot
of interesting rigging going
on here and camera techniques.
But one very simple
thing that I think
is kind of effective
in a good way
is this prop that they have
of the x, y, and z-axis.
And so to show you
what frame of reference
you're going to be in next,
they put it on the cart.
They put it on the table.
And it's just a very,
very simple prop.
It's a very simple
idea, but it really
works because it
kind of prepares you
for the next world you're
going to enter as the camera.
And it's just a nice use of
a prop as a plastic element.
You could have made
the film without it,
but it would have just been that
much more slightly confusing
as to what frame of reference
you were actually in.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And so if you
end up for your final projects,
end up doing a film
on a project where
you want to convey some of
the ideas behind the science,
or whatever it is that you're
going to be doing your work on,
if it ends up being a topic--
some kind of topic like this,
it becomes one of the questions.
Becomes, how do
you convey things
in a way that's both
accurate and insightful
and compelling to the viewer.
Right?
So how do you be accurate
to the science of what
you're trying to convey?
How do you do it in a
way that's insightful,
that allows the
audience to go a-ha,
I got that, and that
and that pulls them in.
And that's tricky.
That's not an easy thing to do.
And it requires a fair
amount of thinking about how
you want to go about doing it.
And so, OK, so this kind
of educational video
obviously is from the point of
view of the scientists wanting
to convey and to educate,
and I mentioned also
you have to think
about these questions
also from the point of
view of the filmmaker.
So again, from the filmmaker,
how do you convey things
in a way-- and obviously what
we're talking about that here
too with Ricky
Leacock, how did he--
presumably he was discussing
with the scientists
about-- the physicists
about how do exactly
do we want to convey this
in a way that's compelling.
But we're going to
be talking later
in class when we get to
Errol Morris and some
of the other things about
four filmmakers making films
about science and scientists.
What kinds of narratives do
they want to draw on, again,
as a way to pull people in.
So we're going to come back
to those kinds of questions
a little bit later in the class.
But the third thing that we want
to talk about in today's class,
a third major use of
science and documentary,
is to satisfy partly popular
fascination with science.
And again, all these
things can overlap too,
so the educational
aspect can overlap
with the popular
interest in science.
And again, around this question
of what are some of the stories
that audiences find fascinating
and want to hear about science.
And Chris and I
had spent some time
trying to think through what
are some of the various ways.
Can I have the chalk?
I think it's supposed
to go that way.
CHRIS BOEBEL: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So
again, this question
of what are some of the
stories that audiences
find fascinating, and want
to hear about science.
We've talked about
some of these before.
There's the element
of spectacle.
And again, think
about IMAX movies
where, again, the
science is a way
to see things about the world
in the way we wouldn't do it
before, and particularly in
ways that are very much visually
arresting and influencing people
on a kind of physical level.
So spectacle like IMAX movies.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Or flies
juggling balls [INAUDIBLE]..
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Flies juggling
balls, as we saw earlier.
Another narrative that
audiences are often
interested in as science
as hero, scientist as hero.
So there's often a fascination
with scientists and thinking
about, well, how did a scientist
heroically go off and discover
something, for
example, that had had
a strong impact upon the world.
So that's a common
kind of narrative
that audiences
are interested in.
Another one is science
as detective story
where audiences are
often fascinated
with how do things get
figured out, thinking
of it like a detective story.
Some people are interested
in thinking about science
in terms of what's the
relationship between reason
and emotion.
With science often
stereotyped as this
being solely about
reason, and what
are the kind of quandaries when
it comes up against emotion.
And obviously the
quintessential example of this
is the early Star Trek movies,
where you have Spock, right?
I mean so Spock is all about
the tension between trying
to be solely about
reason, but having
emotional feelings
at the same time,
and how does he deal with
that kind of relationship.
And often those
kinds of quandaries
get talked about
in popular culture
through a science figure
in there somewhere.
Man, there's too many cords.
OK.
And then there's also
an interest in science
almost for the
bizarre, where science
itself becomes kind of a
science fiction about, wow,
look at this crazy stuff
that science is up to.
It's even crazier than the
actual science fiction.
It's so crazy you
couldn't even make it up.
I mean you've heard
that kind of line
often I think in popular
discussions about science.
So a kind of
fascination with science
about how strange
and odd it can be,
even stranger than things
that could be made up.
So this is kind of the list
that we had come up with.
Can you guys think of others?
Sort of popular ways that people
relate to sides or stories
that they're
interested in hearing
about science or scientists?
AUDIENCE: I guess maybe stories
that have a moral value,
that maybe science
discovering something
causes you to question
the morality of it,
or whether it's [INAUDIBLE].
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
Do you have a specific
example you're thinking of?
AUDIENCE: I was
thinking Jurassic Park.
They learn to bring back
to this ancient animal,
but is that right?
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Right so
the kind of ethical issues,
and the kind of
ethical issues then.
That issue, issues around
cloning, about, oh,
and actually I think we
had had it on this list.
And I forgot to put it up, but
the kind of moral quandaries
around scientists playing God.
Like when is it OK?
To push when is it OK
to push human knowledge
and what people can
do and when does
it cross a line
into something that
is potentially morally suspect.
Yeah, exactly where
is the line that we
want to draw here or not.
So that kind of fascination
with those kinds of stories.
How do we think about
that relationship?
Sabrina?
AUDIENCE: Coolness
factor of personality?
Like sort of like Brian
Greene in the [INAUDIBLE]
[? universe ?] is
very entertaining.
The person presenting it is
trying to turn [INAUDIBLE]..
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah, that's
kind of a subset of scientists
as hero.
Scientists as cool.
The science is cool.
Yeah.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Science as cool.
And a focus on-- that's
supposed to be as cool.
And then also the focus
on particular kind
of charismatic
individuals who are
seen as conveying a certain
kind of image of science
that people want to respond to.
[? Anahita. ?]
AUDIENCE: Do you think about
some examples of science
as the superior to human
being the [INAUDIBLE]
like in the movie
[INAUDIBLE] 2001
when the robots are the
science [INAUDIBLE]..
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So when does
science become the villain?
AUDIENCE: Right, when science
become smarter than humans,
or overcomes the
human [? subjects. ?]
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So
and again, that kind
of question of when
does science become
about human hubris, where
it surpasses itself,
and then the technology
or the science
becomes a danger back
to humans themselves.
And so you would see that around
in the 1950s when you think
about all the pop
culture movies that
were kind of veiled
or overt references
to nuclear technologies,
or other kinds of things.
That with people struggling with
the question of when do things
go beyond a certain
point, where the worry
becomes about the science
itself coming back
and its impact on people.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And
more recently, you
have a whole the
Matrix franchise,
the Terminator franchise,
which are about AI
and technologies that
become their own creators
and then reject the human
beings that created them.
And attempt to destroy them.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Sabrina?
AUDIENCE: Science as
like a competition, when
you have different people trying
to do the same thing and making
it seem like [INAUDIBLE].
CHRISTINE WALLEY: A fascination
with science as competition,
about which becomes part
of the discovery process,
in a way, except you've got
the added element of drama
with competition, about who's
going to crack the DNA code,
or what were these kinds of
scientific competitions about.
How do people discover
things, and that added element
of drama.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
kind of science
as creating history,
and creating the future.
So a lot of representations
of new things there,
as if the future has been
brought to the present.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: I think--
so science almost as a way
for people to think about
the future and the possibilities
that the future might bring,
or to [INAUDIBLE] Yeah, I
think that happens a lot,
when in popular cultural
representations when people
think about their nervousness or
concerns or worries about what
the future--
or their hopes for
that matter, too,
about what the
future might bring.
Often that future is
expressed through a reference
to science and technology
and what it might
do, rather than other kinds
of social issues per se,
because, I mean, again, I mean
how do we know necessarily
what the future is
going to be about?
But science and
technology is often
used to represent what we think
the future is going to be.
So yeah, so the way--
it's the symbolic connotations,
the symbolic relationship
that it has to certain
kinds of ideas about time.
And seen as being representative
of the future. [? Anahita? ?]
AUDIENCE: I mean,
[INAUDIBLE] little bit
with the idea of
[INAUDIBLE],, but also creates
that kind of hierarchy of
power [INAUDIBLE] when you
see the science fiction movie.
And especially I think it's more
relevant to the younger people,
like feeling that all
this is the scientist
[INAUDIBLE] hierarchy
at all, they
have all these resources, and
this position to [INAUDIBLE]
be heroes for the future
or do all this cool things.
But here I am looking at it.
So it's like it's a
hierarchy between you
and whatever is going on.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So a
kind of concern with, OK,
who are these people who have
this authority, who are making
these kinds of decisions, that
I don't necessarily have input
into, and are they people
doing this for the greater
good in a way that's
going to help me,
or is this potentially
very-- the decisions
that they're going
to make are going
to be extremely problematic.
AUDIENCE: Science is power.
So people who have the science
are the powerful people,
and if I want to be powerful,
I have to have the science.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And
kind of the narrative
of the disconnected scientist.
The scientist who-- which is,
again, a little like science
versus emotion.
The scientist who stands
apart, who has this power,
but who doesn't understand
what the power can do,
or it doesn't have
a relationship
to people, average
people who are going
to be affected by something.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Yeah, I mean I think
all this is really important to
get out, because there's both,
again, what people
on the science end
might want to convey
to the public,
and then there's also
on the public end
what is the fascination
with the scientists,
and what are the concerns
and quandaries and things
that people are interested
in thinking about
in relation to science.
And obviously, it's not
just the separate thing.
We have the scientists over
here, pop culture over here.
I mean one of the things
that's really fascinating when
we talk about this
later in class
is if you talk to
many people at MIT,
and actually this
is going to come up
in relation to the next
film we're going to see.
But if you talk to
many people around MIT
of a certain
generation, they might
have gotten interested in doing
what they do because maybe they
were really fascinated with
Star Trek when they were kids.
And they decided, air astro, I
mean that's where I want to go.
And so a lot of
times if you go back
and you talk to
people, what originally
got interested in
thinking about this,
often people will refer back to
pop cultural images from when
they were a kid about
whether it's, again,
Star Trek or actually this--
this is actually a good
segue into this next video
that we're going to see,
because according to Chris
a number of people that
he's talked to around MIT
mentioned this.
This series of Connections
had been on the BBC
as something that very
much influenced them
when they were younger, when
they decided that they wanted
to become scientists.
So OK, so I'll use that
as a segue into this.
And so this series,
Connections that I just
mentioned, it's mostly
in that kind of genre
of science as detective story.
I mean obviously, it's also
meant to be partly educational,
but also science
as detective story.
It's a series that came out in
the late 1970s and the narrator
is this guy James Burke.
He was an Irishman who
was trained at Oxford,
and he became a science
journalist at the BBC.
And so this ended up
becoming a very famous series
on science and technology.
And so we're going to watch part
of the first episode of this.
He was often described as
being kind of the Sherlock
Holmes of science.
OK, I'm not going to
say any more than that.
I'll just let you respond
and see what you all.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And I'll just say,
try to think about this film,
and I mean all the other films
that we've been seeing as well,
but this one in particular from
the point of view of narrative
strategies.
Keeping the audience
engaged and how
that relates to the information
that's being imparted.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And
again, this series
was an extremely
popular series, and they
had a lot of funding to do it.
But extremely popular series
that was quite influential.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah.
As Chris mentioned, if you
talk to a lot of professors
in their 40s who were
teenagers when this came out,
a lot of them will say, oh I
saw, Connections on PBS when
I was a kid, and that was it.
I wanted to be an
engineer or a scientist.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And
again, this tendency.
We often have a
tendency to think
of like, well science is
the serious stuff over here,
and like the pop
culture stuff is the not
serious stuff over here.
But again, as human
beings we get influenced
by all of this stuff, right?
And so the pop culture
representations
become part of
who we are and why
we're interested in these
questions to begin with,
and they might be what pushes
people into a certain direction
to ask certain
kinds of questions.
So in a way, it's
kind of what we
want to be thinking
about both ends
and the potential relationship
that's out there as well.
And we actually have a class
later on in the semester
that specifically on science
fiction that's partly
around these kind of very kinds
of questions about how science
moves over in to the pop
culture realm, and the influence
back and forth between science
and the world of fiction.
CHRIS BOEBEL: But
here you're going
to see a science documentary
that, among other things,
is very heavily influenced
by the world of fiction
filmmaking.
OK?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Would you do me a favor?
I'd like to stop
talking for a minute,
and when I do, take a
look at the room you're
in, and above all at
the man made objects
in that room that surround you.
The television set, the
lights, the phone, and so on.
And ask yourself what those
objects do to your life
just because they're there.
Go ahead.
Well, that is what this series
is going to be all about.
It's about the things
that surround you
in the modern world, and just
because they're there shape
the way you think and behave.
And why they exist
in the form they do.
And who or what was responsible
for them existing at all.
The search for those clues will
take us all over the world,
and 12,000 years into the past.
Because it's in those strange
places and in those long gone
centuries that the secret
of the modern world lies.
And you'll never believe
the extraordinary things
that led to us being
the way we are today.
Things like, for instance,
why a 16th century
doctor at the Court
of Queen Elizabeth
did something that made
it possible for you
to watch this screen now.
Or the fact that because
18th century merchants were
worried about ship's bottoms,
you have nylon to wear.
Or why a group of French
monks and their involvement
with sheep rearing helped
to give the modern world
the computer.
Or what medieval Europeans
did with their fire
in winter that led to
motorcar manufacture.
[CHANTING]
The story of the events and the
people who over centuries came
together to bring
us in from the cold
and to wrap us in a warm
blanket of technology
is a matter of vital
importance, since more and more
of that technology infiltrates
every aspect of our lives.
It's become a life
support system
without which we can't survive.
And yet how much of
it do we understand?
Do I bother myself
with the reality
of what happens when I
get into a big steel box,
press the button, and
rise into the sky?
Of course, I don't.
[END PLAYBACK]
CHRISTINE WALLEY: OK,
reactions, comments?
AUDIENCE: So it's
like a reenactment,
but it's like so theatrical
that it's really interesting.
AUDIENCE: The pace at
which it's narrated,
it's very fast and
anxious, and like when he
was talking about the count--
it wasn't necessarily
a countdown,
but as the minutes were
passing until the blackout was
happening.
It just made-- it
just emphasized
like how fast paced the city
was, and then everything just
stopped and it
slowed down and it
was as if time froze because
technology wasn't [INAUDIBLE]
so I kind of like that.
The way they said that.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Other
reactions, comments?
AUDIENCE: It is really
powerful how it constantly
takes things that the
audience takes for granted
and reveals them to be
extraordinary and ephemeral
and not, yeah, kind of
exoticised them and show them
in their capacity
of breaking down.
So it was just kind of
romantic notion of in the end,
everything is one tiny little
bit can make everything
else fall apart, and it's
really just looks like a fiction
movie.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
So stylistically, right?
So it's filmed as a--
well, you also have to see the
relationship between this one
this, this is the first episode,
and some of the other episodes
in the series.
So this one focuses
on New York City
as the modern
technological metropolis.
A lot of the other
episodes in the series
travel to different
parts of the world,
and in different
historical time periods.
So it might start off in--
it might be about the
development of the printing
press, and it might go
back to the Middle Ages.
But it's following some
technology historically
through time, and how
this technology triggered
all these kinds of impacts.
And so the idea is to take
things that you would never
expect and trace
back its genealogy
and to argue that
while it was linked
to this kind of
technological transformation
that happened in this part
of the world and this time
that you never would
have suspected.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Basically,
I mean the thesis is just
as an example,
the second episode
begins with the
coining of money.
The first money
several thousand--
over 2,000 years ago,
and traces this argument
that the direct result of
that was the development
of the atomic bomb.
And traces a technological
evolutionary connection
argument from one to the other,
with multiple steps in between.
So the connection
in that instance
is the connection between
this one tiny accident
of technology in one
part of the world
with the next one, with the
next one, with the next one.
So this is kind an
interesting thematic way
of getting into it, because
he's looking at a network
and how one tiny
piece of a network
can have these
massive repercussions
across the network.
Which is exactly what he
then says about technology
throughout the
rest of the series.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So there's
two questions to be asked then.
I mean, so once you know
where the rest of the series
is going, and then it set
up as this detective series
through time and across space.
How do they convey
aesthetically the sense
that this is a detective story?
And if you think back,
I mean, how many of you
have watched old
film noir movies?
The film noir genre, the
old black and white where--
so the shots of him with
half his face in shadow,
wearing the overcoat.
You don't-- there's a lot
of darkness in here, right?
That's the old film noir style.
So it's deliberately
drawing on the earlier film
noir style of the late
'40s or early '50s,
that's right chronologically,
darkness, in shadow, to convey
that sense to audiences
that would have been
very familiar with that genre.
The sense that, ah, this is some
dark mysterious detective story
that we're going to
be taking you on.
So one question is about the
kinds of aesthetic choices
that they made to convey
the kind of narrative
that they wanted to
convey about science,
that this is a detective story.
So that's one question.
And then the other thing, as
Chris was just describing,
the relationship between
the different episodes,
it gets to this
question about accuracy.
I mean so this--
so the way they have doing this.
Well, so you start out with
this transformation here
and it has these incredible
repercussions way over here.
And then one of the questions
that we kind of always
have about the series, is
how much just it ended up
being just so stories, and I
mean can you really kind of do
that kind of linking in
quite the way that it does.
CHRIS BOEBEL: They're all
very cool and interesting
connections, but the
question is, at what point
are they serving a
narrative and at what point
are they really interest--
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Not really in
any kind of logical connection,
but they're just
asserting a connection
because it's good thematically.
Or narratively speaking.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Let's
take a quick break.
So we have the entire
series of this in the lab,
if anybody's interested.
I mean they do make these
very compelling stories
and whether they're just
so stories, as Chris said,
or whether they actually
have something legit to say
about how one technology
feeds another.
It's probably a bit of both.
It's probably kind of a
mix of narrative flourish
and substance.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: But
certainly they're fun to watch,
and they were, as we mentioned,
very influential in getting
certain people to be interested
in these kinds of questions
and want to explore them
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well,
and I think in how
people think about
science and technology,
and in a kind of an
evolutionary way.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So at this
point any final comments on--
any final comments
on Connections?
AUDIENCE: I think
it's just funny how
whenever there's
a mystery movie,
it's they always like it has
to be like someone British
or with an accent.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Right, exactly.
Exactly.
AUDIENCE: Any of like dark
and maybe like damp sort of.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah, exactly.
And what's funny, one of
the things that I think
is absolutely hysterical,
well, he has an overcoat on,
so you don't see it
a lot, but he always
wears this tan leisure suit.
And so you go through
all the episodes,
he's always got the
tan leisure suit on,
so it's like that's
one of the things
that they use as an
element of continuity
throughout a lot of the videos.
But as you say, the British
accent, the kind of collar
turned up, the
film noir lighting.
So again, through various
kinds of aesthetic choices,
and how people are dressed,
what kinds of things
get conveyed when you go to
make your final projects?
How do those kinds
of aesthetic elements
affect the kind of
narrative that's
going to end up being told?
OK, so just to summarize
some of this up.
So one of the things
we've been wanting
to think about here
is the question,
or at least get out on the
table, what kinds of narratives
have commonly been
told about science
through documentary film?
And there's been certain
genres of documentary
filmmaking about
science that have
been more common than others.
For example, this kind
of detective version,
or the educational
film, or whatever it is.
But one of the other questions
that we want to throw out
is, what kinds of
narratives about science
have not been commonly told?
Right?
And I think there's a lot of
other narratives out there
about science and technology
that haven't necessarily
been told a whole lot.
And so Chris and I, when we
were thinking about setting up
this class, I mean one of
the things that we tried
to think about was
the direct cinema
style which we're going to talk
about in a couple of weeks.
But if you think again back
to that film primary where
it's like hand-held
cameras, focusing
on the action moving around.
It's much rarer,
for example, to see
films made about science
and technology that
draw upon those kinds
of techniques compared
to some others, or certain
kinds of narratives
that would come out of that
kind of style of filmmaking.
And so one of the
things that we want
you to be thinking about
through the course of this class
is, OK, so there's the
more common narratives that
get told about science, and
those might be very compelling,
and you might very
well want to draw
a final project that draws on
some of those kinds of genres.
Or you might also
want to be thinking
about what kinds of
stories about science
haven't been told as much
that maybe I want to tell.
OK?
So we want to keep
it all open to you,
and get you thinking
about all of those.
And the way we tried
to set up the class
is that throughout
the course, you're
going to be exposed to
lots of different kinds
of documentary
filmmaking techniques,
as well as a whole range of
different kinds of narrative
styles for talking about
science and documentary.
So the idea is to give
you a broad toolkit
both in terms of the
kinds of narratives
you might want to use, or
you might want to be telling,
but also in terms of
the kinds of techniques
or styles of shooting that
you might want to engage in.
So the idea is to give
you this-- present
this whole range of things.
And then this is your toolbox.
And you get to decide what kind
of story do you want to tell,
and it order to tell that
story, what kinds of tools
do you want to use?
What kind of narrative
do you want to convey?
What kind of narrative best gets
at what you want to get across?
OK?
So that is the idea for that.
Anything to add onto that?
CHRIS BOEBEL: No, I think
that's a good summary.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: OK.
So then before we end
then the last little thing
that we want to do
is just talk a bit
more about your final
project so that you're
thinking more about that.
Again, I know-- so Sabrina
and Jessica and Katrina,
and both of you, you were also
at the DV lab screening, right?
At the museum?
So I don't if there was any
reaction to those things
that you thought
were interesting
as topics or narratives or
things to potentially explore,
or things that you
might have thought
would have been interesting
kinds of projects
that weren't necessarily--
didn't necessarily be made.
Anyway, any kind of responses
to the ones that you saw,
or if you just want
to skip to what
you're potentially
interested in doing.
I don't know how much thought
you've put into what you do.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Obviously this
is very casual at this point.
There is kind of
a formal process
later in the class of people
presenting ideas, and being
able to pick between
several ideas,
hopefully, so that you
don't have to settle very,
very quickly on something.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Right.
So right at this
stage now we just
want preliminary just to get you
starting to think about stuff.
And even if you have the
vaguest idea or maybe you
don't even have any idea.
I mean any of that's OK.
But I'm just wondering
what you're potentially
thinking about doing.
And something else
to think about
is, again, this is a class--
it's not film school.
Right?
You don't have massive
amounts of time.
Also, you have to be
thinking about if you
want to tell a particular
story, do you have enough time
to be able to tell that story?
Right?
So we're not asking you to
do these massive projects.
And keep in mind again that
the DV lab videos that you saw,
students worked on
it one semester.
But then they also had
a half class follow up
where they just worked
on whatever project
that they were doing.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Most of
them came out of that.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: A
few of them were just
from the first semester.
But for your final
project, so we're
not expecting some
half hour piece.
In fact, we would encourage
people to keep it small.
How would you?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well, time wise
certainly probably under 10
minutes, realistically.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Somewhere
between two and 10 minutes.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Some the ones
we saw on Friday were longer.
But again, they had
longer to work on them.
AUDIENCE: It was
interesting to see
with the contrast between
Tom's piece and Emily's piece,
and I was trying to see
where I want situate myself
along this continuum.
Just go somewhere and
shoot everything and trying
to get to shoot interesting
things and people saying things
that have some kind of powerful
narrative input in themselves.
And then getting
lots of material
is also kind of the
point and, then you
have this incredible
editing problem.
And I think Tom went a
completely different process
also for the nature of the
questions he was asking
and started going through
[? tell ?] and to completely
construct everything, and
basically have actors.
[INAUDIBLE] the controversy,
so you had the guy on Skype.
Then you had PhD student
talking about the lab, and--
CHRISTINE WALLEY: The
electron microscopy lab,
with the conflict within.
And Emily's piece at the
end, hers was one about.
Yeah, the cows, the
agricultural fair.
So and [? Ty, ?]
you weren't there,
but so the first
piece is much more
interview based talking
about this controversy
within the lab.
And we can raise there a
certain-- the kind of question,
too, about what kinds of things
can you get access to or not.
And he ended up
having reenactments
because he couldn't get access
to certain kinds of things,
which we should talk about.
And then Emily's piece, much
more observational style,
where it's more quietly
going around with the camera
and just watching
what people are doing.
CHRIS BOEBEL: There
is a big-- actually
a strong similarity to the
two pieces in the origination,
however, because both of them
started out with an idea,
with an abstract
idea, not a story,
or a profile of a person.
Tom wanted to talk about
some fairly abstract things
about imaging, and
what images mean,
and what the relationship
between something
you see and evidence.
And also to start to take a
look at this controversy which
had happened in the
past, the people
had left MIT, except
for one person.
He had no material on it,
no footage or anything.
So he had to find a story
to put all of that stuff on.
And create it as he went along.
And Emily basically went
to the fair with this idea
that she wanted to shoot
things that involved animal
human interactions,
and she had to find
a story in the edit room.
She just shot for three or four
days, shot a lot of material,
and found a really nice
interesting narrative
with all of these
kind of connections
that get made through the film.
So again, the idea
in both situations
was that they didn't have a
strong narrative like a process
or a profile of a
person or a competition.
A lot of the things that
we were just talking about,
they had to find those
things as they went along.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: What Chris
means is that some of this
like detective story,
it has intrinsic to it
a certain kind of narrative arc.
But if you don't enter--
or a competition,
if you film a competition.
That has its own kind of
narrative arc built into it.
But if you're
filming a topic that
doesn't have a kind of
drama that's automatically
built into the
topic, then you have
to create the narrative thread.
And so you do it through
editing or through other kinds
of means.
CHRIS BOEBEL: An
example of something
that has a built in
narrative arc, last year
one of the students for an
earlier project shot a very
interesting fun little film
about the pie eating contest
at Pi Day.
And it was great.
People sit down, who's
going to win, pies.
It's fun.
There's all sorts
of interesting--
oh no, not the pie eating
contest, the naming the numbers
of pi.
How many places of pi you name.
And there's pie
at the end of it.
So but it's a
competition, there are
interesting quirky
characters and moments.
You get kind of involved
in who's going to win.
Somebody wins.
And there's a denouement.
So there's a narrative
built into the story.
And she went in knowing what
the narrative was going to be.
Right, and somebody also
did a very fun piece
on student elections,
running for office.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So and
then somebody wins, right?
So again, there's closure to it.
So there are certain
kinds of topics
you can pick that are
easier in some sense
because they have
built into them, again,
a certain kind of drama.
And if you decide you
want to do a topic that
might be incredibly
fascinating and wonderful to do
that doesn't have
that, again, it just
means you just have to do
some additional kind of work
in terms of thinking
about how you're
going to draw out or
create some kind of story.
Because ultimately,
in order for anybody
to want to watch something, you
have to have some kind of story
be there.
You have to be saying something
with what it is that you shoot.
OK?
And maybe that at the beginning.
Maybe not when you start
the shooting process.
I mean again, people
come to these things
in very different kinds of ways.
A kind of a very anthropological
approach to shooting
would be, OK, well, I'm
interested in this topic
kind of like Emily with
the agricultural fair.
I'm interested in animal
human interactions,
but I'm not going
to assume anything
about what I'm going to find.
I'm just going to go and shoot.
And I'm gonna see, and I'm
going to think about it,
and then I've got
all this footage,
and I'm going to ponder that.
Well, what was that about?
And then through the
process of pondering that,
you decide like, oh, this is
kind of what this is about.
And you start to put together
the visual images in a way
that kind of tell that story.
So some people have it more kind
of as a process of exploration
in the world, and
you pull it out.
And others kind of have
something either more
built into the event itself, or
people have some kind of story
that they want to
tell more clearly,
and they're looking
to illustrate it.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And
then the other thing I
think we both
encourage you to think
about are stories of
Science and Technology
that are nontraditional.
I mean, there are
the lab stories.
But we define science and
technology pretty broadly.
In fact, really broadly.
The puppet theater
is not exactly--
I mean there's, again, a craft
portion to what they're doing,
craft technology, but it's a
pretty broad interpretation
of what a science or technology
related film would be.
And there are a lot of really
interesting things going
on at MIT right now that
we would both encourage
you to think about.
There's the Festival of Art,
Science, and Technology,
which is just filled with really
interesting events and projects
and happenings between now
and the end of the semester.
There are multiple
possibilities there for a film.
Which isn't to say
that a fantastic
film about lab research is
not a great way to go too.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Which
could really terrific.
There's also the 150th
is going on now too,
so you could do a film about MIT
reflecting on itself at 150th.
You know so it
doesn't have to be
MIT'S narrative
about itself, but it
could be your take on what
they're presenting is that.
I'm just trying to throw
out other things that
are out there going around
that are happening right now.
Things that are
happening right now
are obviously easier to shoot.
I mean, we did the
film that Christa--
that I helped out on, Chris--
I think I mentioned
this in the first class,
he did a film about the 19--
documentary about the
1979 nuclear accident
at Three Mile Island.
So we were making the film
much after the accident.
So there's interviews with
all the people in the area.
But there's also a strong
reliance on archival footage,
and getting people to
talk about the past.
And so the film becomes very
much about memory, as well.
So if you want to get
at a historical topic,
there's a whole
other range of issues
that you have to deal with if
it's stuff that's not happening
in the current moment.
How do you tell that story?
If it's something that's
happening right now,
I mean, that's something
that's really well-suited
to say the direct
cinema style, which
is a very kind of observational
style where just go out
and explore that
thing that's going on.
But if you want to do
something about the past,
you can do something
about Doc Edgerton.
You can do something about--
I mean, God knows what.
I mean there's a zillion topics.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And just, I think
as we've mentioned before,
film tends to love action.
It loves movement.
It loves activity.
Action films is not just what
we think of as action films.
I mean, films are about actions.
And that isn't to say that you
can't start with a very, very
abstract idea, but you
just need to come up
with a strategy for turning
that abstract idea into actions.
And if you think about the
clip of Fast, Cheap, and Out
of Control that we saw that has
this very, very abstract idea
about groups and networks
and controlling nature,
and Rodney Brooks,
it's brought alive
with all of this a found
footage, archival footage,
cartoons, all of this
stuff sore of montaged
together, edited together
in a very interesting way.
Emily had a very abstract
idea, but what was great
was that she had
people doing stuff.
Competing in various
competitions, this fair,
it was incredibly visual.
Movement, lots of
animals running around.
So it became very easy for
her to turn that abstract idea
into something that
was film friendly.
Tom, of course,
had to use actors.
That was his choice,
to make his--
turn his abstract idea and his
thing that happened in the past
into actions.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Well, and
there was the related issue,
which we should at
least mention, too,
that there's issue of access
and what you can get permission
for.
And again, there's
permission forms
that when you go
to do interviews,
you have to get permission
from people when you do this.
And one of the issues about--
I mean, we were strongly
encouraging people
last semester, again,
to go out and try
to explore new
narratives about science,
and the idea of
doing a more kind
of focusing on
science's process,
and getting some
of the day to day
of how science and
engineering actually plays out
in a day to day way
is really fascinating.
Something that hasn't
been done that much.
But there's also, if you choose
to go that route, which I think
is a really fabulous route to
go, and I'd encourage you--
I mean that's one route that
could be really cool to do.
But one of the difficulties
with that that students
last semester found
out was that you
have to think about,
there might be
a lot of issues around
permissions, for example.
Right?
So what would happen was
that a number of the students
last semester, they found
some totally cool thing
that was happening in
some lab on campus.
And they had friends who
were graduate students,
the graduate student was
like, yeah, this is great,
and maybe they did
preliminary interviews
with that grad student,
and fantastic stuff.
But then they had to ask the
PI of that graduate student
and the PI said no.
Because there's worry in
certain labs, understandably,
that if stuff gets out
before it's been published,
it's kind of a
pre-publication kind of--
what's going on
inside the lab is
going to be
disseminated in a way
that they don't necessarily
want, if it hasn't necessarily
been published yet.
And then there's also--
I mean, for obvious
reasons people
like to control the
images of themselves.
Right?
So if you're the head of a lab,
and you've got funding sources,
it's not surprising
that people want
to control the image
that's going to come out
of their laboratory, the same
way that at MIT in general
there's sometimes a desire to
control what's the image of MIT
that that's going to come out.
So that doesn't mean
you can't get permission
to do those kinds of
things, but it might
take longer than you think.
So that was one
of the things that
stuck some of the students.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Don't assume.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: That
slowed them down a bit.
CHRIS BOEBEL:
Think about who you
need to give you the final
say that you can do a project,
if it involves things like that.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And
really explain to them
what you're planning
on doing, what
you're not planning on doing.
We've been putting the ones--
the class videos that
we've had permissions for,
we've put them up online,
but you don't necessarily
have to do that.
If you want to just shoot it
as an exercise for yourself,
you can tell them
that it's not going
to go up anywhere beyond that,
and then we abide by that.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Although we
would, for your final projects
we would strongly
encourage you to try
to get the necessary
permissions so that it
can be published online.
Because it's just
better for you.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah,
if you do a final project
and you put a ton
of work into it.
CHRIS BOEBEL: You want
to able to share it.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Yeah, you're going
to be sad then at the end
you can't show it to anybody
other than the class.
CHRIS BOEBEL: But there are
also creative workarounds.
I mean, for those of you
who were there Friday night.
Max Dennis did the film
about the researcher slash
stand up comic, and
basically he was not
allowed to say what lab he
worked in, what exactly he did.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Because he
was feeding cocaine to rats.
And so they didn't want-- the
lab didn't want that disgust.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Although
he had all this YouTube.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Right,
so he discussed it
without talking about exactly
what school he went to,
which wasn't MIT,
what lab he worked in.
Any of his co-workers,
any of that.
All of that was out of it.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So it
was made a joke out of,
which in a way that worked.
So this is something
that's different for those
of us who are used to doing--
I mean, those of us who work in
the social sciences, the way we
usually handle this
in our written work
is that we use pseudonyms.
That's how we give
protection to the people
that we do our research
on, is we use pseudonyms.
So that people have privacy and
there's not harmful outcomes
to them in the end.
But when you're doing video
work, you can't do that.
So that imposes certain
kinds of constraints
in terms of what
stories you can tell,
or how you would
do it in the way
that Tom dealt with
that, because he
was dealing with
controversies within a lab.
That were very-- they were--
passions were strong
around those controversies,
and it stood to affect
people's reputations.
And it could have-- some of
the graduate students felt,
like, well, it could have
affect their reputation.
It would make it difficult for
them to get work afterwards.
So the way that
he dealt with that
is that he had his friends
re-enact those scenes,
and it was-- and
all of his friends
were students who
had worked in labs
and experience
something different.
So it was actually
kind of this fun thing
where they got to act out-- like
the drama within their own lab
groups.
So it ended up being a
really fun kind of reflection
on what they
actually do, but that
was a really creative way
he got around that issue.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And
the other thing
is he embargoed the
film all of last year.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Until the last person
left MIT who had been involved.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And now
it's on the front page
of Tech TV as of today.
Because we can finally show it.
Because everybody's left MIT.
So.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
Anyway, so we've done
a lot of talking now,
but just any of you
have any ideas yet
on what potentially
you might want to do,
or whether something
might be feasible?
AUDIENCE: After
seeing the videos,
I realize like it would have
been really helpful according
to a lot of them to work with
the another person, a partner.
So Ty and I were thinking
of doing a film about ROTC.
And like [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: What's yours?
AUDIENCE: ROTC is the Reserve
Officer Training Corps.
And so like, it would show
how their students are not
only like preparing
to be soldiers,
but also their engineering
and like science
like educational background,
and how they balance it.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah,
that's a fascinating topic.
Just to clarify one
thing, everybody
does have to do their own
film project at the end.
But you can still work together.
I mean, what Tom was
talking about was when--
the idea is, and this is the way
commonly works in film school,
is that when people are
working on their projects,
you draw on your classmates
to help you to do sound,
or to help while
you're interviewing,
maybe somebody does
the camera, because you
need to be able to
talk and interact.
So part of the idea is that you
build a cohort as time goes on,
and other people help you, and
then you help them in turn.
And it really does help the
whole quality of the filmmaking
process.
So there is this kind of
collaborative collective aspect
to making this stuff that
we would really encourage.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So we would
encourage you to work in teams,
but to do--
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
So the outcome would
have to be separate
to be graded,
it would have to be
graded separately.
But you can even do--
I mean--
CHRIS BOEBEL: If you do
two related projects.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah, exactly.
I mean so you could do the same
topic, if you wanted, and have
two different takes
on it, or two--
but for two different
visual products at the end.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So if you
both did films on ROTC
and shared a lot of
the camera duties,
you would still need to
edit your own projects.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Because part of it,
in terms of grading to
be able to that people
got the basics of how
to shoot, how to edit.
Because again, we
don't want to, as we
said in the very
first class, we don't
want to have to grade people
on just the final product
and how aesthetically
good it is,
because people may
be coming from very
different backgrounds.
But so we also want to do a
fair amount of the grading
in terms of amount of
effort that people put into.
And if it's done
collaboratively,
we can't tell if one
person did 3/4 of the work,
and one person did a quarter,
it's harder for us to judge.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And
you could certainly
shoot collaboratively,
and we would strongly
encourage everybody to do that.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Does that
make sense, or is that--
OK.
AUDIENCE: So how--
I mean, let's say we
have a topic in mind,
but we don't much about it.
So we don't know what kind
of stories there are there.
So what's the best way?
Would you just go
and start filming?
And like I realized
the other day
we were filming just the
very basic kind of scene
of like somebody
chopping things,
then there was a story to it.
I mean there was a
kind of relationship,
very sensual relationship with
vegetables, which I wouldn't
have thought about until
when I could hear the sounds,
and the vegetables
being eaten, and like
seems like the beauty of--
and it really came out
only when I was looking
at it through the camera.
So or should you think about
it more before starting?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well, there's
an interesting answer
which comes out of the
technology that we're using.
The way to begin a project
like some of these projects
are traditionally would
have been to go do some pre
interviews, to do a site visit.
If you're-- say you're
doing something on a lab.
You go visit the lab
without a camera.
You interview the researchers.
You just get the
lay of the land.
You start you look for stories.
And the advantage of
that is that they see you
as a human being before
they see you as a camera.
And that's really,
really important
because you make a human
connection before you jump up
and take out the camera,
stick it in their face
and say, be in my movie.
But on the other hand, the
great thing about these cameras
is that they're so small
that you can just throw them
in your bag and bring them.
And so what I often
do, and what I
would think that you
might want to consider
is do exactly what I just said.
Set up a site visit
with no camera,
go in and meet the
people, but if you
have the camera in your bag
and you're sensitive enough
and have your antenna out
enough about what's going on,
at some point it may be OK
and just completely natural
for you to take out the camera.
And you obviously need
to ask before you do it.
You need to make sure that
you've kind of established
a rapport and that
everything is good,
and they're enthusiastic
and interested.
And you'll want to listen to
yourself and your own instincts
about whether or
not want to shoot.
Because as you said, you
start seeing things really
differently through the camera.
And you have ideas that you
wouldn't have necessarily
had if you're just
talking to the people.
And I've been on the other
side of that coin, where
I'm on a site visit or some
kind of pre-production thing,
and I realize, oh my God, why
didn't I bring the camera?
There's some amazing
stuff happening here,
why can't I shoot it?
But you just have to be
aware that, if you walk in
with a camera right off the bat,
on your shoulder ready to go,
you may alienate the people.
And it's kind of a rude way
of introducing yourself.
So this gives you the
best of both worlds.
Go make a site visit,
don't plan to film,
but have the camera in your bag.
And if the moment is right,
and the rapport is good,
and something really
fascinating is happening,
you can ask and film.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And kind of
on the even more extreme end
from that, say people with
anthropological training who
go to make documentary
films, sometimes they'll
spend a year before they
even take out a camera.
And depending on where you
are, and if what's going on
is really socially
sensitive, that people
will spend that time just
building relationships, knowing
what's going on, developing that
sense of relationship and trust
with people.
So that when they actually
go and pull out the camera,
it's a completely different
product in the end,
because you can feel
the kind of interaction
between the people who are
being filmed and the filmmaker,
and it's completely
different than somebody
who just came in for a couple
of days to shoot something.
It's a totally
different product.
And so I can try to remember
now what films we're showing you
for the ethnographic
film section.
But maybe I'll switch
it a bit and try
to pull out some that convey
that kind of long term
relationship.
So in some cases, when people
have the time and the money
and the ability to
do it, people will
spend a year or so in advance
just building relationships
before they ever start filming.
So obviously you can't do that.
But.
CHRIS BOEBEL: I mean,
the other thing is to--
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
But just to emphasize
the importance of the
social relationships
and establishing the
comfort level of the people
that you're working
with is really crucial.
CHRIS BOEBEL: That's the key.
But I was going
to say, even there
has been a shift I
think with video,
because video is so
cheap, and the cameras
are so small and so ubiquitous
that you still spend the year
or more building
the relationships,
but you can introduce
the camera sooner.
And then the camera just kind
of disappears, eventually.
So-- but it's the
same principle.
You've got to be seen
as a human being,
and have that human relationship
before you become a camera.
And if you do it at the
right pace or the best
pace you possibly can given
your time and your budget
and your schedule,
the camera will
be more likely to disappear.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And
this is why it's better
often to have two people-- if
you do have I mean some of you
might be doing sit down
interviews, and some of you
might be doing
handheld where you
want it to be about
action, about movement,
and you don't want to
do sit down interviews.
But if you do decide
you want to do--
well, either way.
Either way you do it.
If you're going to
be talking to people
and have them talking back
directly to the camera,
with comfort level,
people are often
much more comfortable
talking, again, to--
I'd be much more
comfortable talking to you
if you didn't have
a camera in my face.
So this is, again, where it's
really helpful to team up.
That if you have somebody
else going with you,
maybe somebody else could
help do the camera work,
and maybe Katrina's is filming
me, but I'm talking to you.
And you're really
paying attention to me,
because you're not
worrying about the camera
and whether it's
exposed right, and all
these other kinds of questions.
And we can establish a
certain kind of relationship
that somebody else can film.
And it makes it a more
intimate interaction.
So this is, again, where
it's helpful to have
some-- potentially have
somebody else go with.
So you as a filmmaker,
you might either choose
that you would
rather do the filming
and have the other person do
the interviewing, or vise versa.
But it's often helpful to have
somebody just kind of do--
be about the social
relationship part.
And somebody else focusing on
the technical ends, like our--
do we have, again, the exposure
right, and the focus right,
and our wires all
tangled up in a mess.
And the batteries.
Have someone focusing on that.
CHRIS BOEBEL: One just one
last thing on this topic.
A lot of really interesting
work has come out
of this class when people
have filmed their friends,
and the reason for that is
that people are obviously very
comfortable with each other.
There's a lot of trust, if
you're filming your friends.
So some great work has happened.
The downside of that is that
you're not taking yourself out
of a comfort zone
as a filmmaker.
You're doing-- you're
shooting fish in a barrel.
So I have I have mixed
feelings about that.
And I would say
about that there are
a number of intermediary
steps before you
do your final project.
There are a lot of small
things along the way.
And you might
experiment with kind
of both sides of that
coin, doing a topic
and filming people that
you know very well.
And then kind of taking yourself
out of that comfort zone.